just a few of us kind of out in the
woods you know pretend there were
zombies around it was just this like
unbelievably humble production you know
we didn't have trailers we didn't have
you know it was just a group of like
real badass people who were like really
believed in this and walking dead you
know look man we got done last night the
first thing I did is I went straight to
go meet Stephen and Melissa Norman and
like they're my family they're they'll
they'll they'll those folks will will
always be my family and in my heart you
know like the way that that show started
it just wasn't a phenomenon it was just
started on the backs of like real hard
work and belief and and I'm so grateful
I got to be there then you know I'm
saying and then I'm so grateful that I
got to get at you know that I get to go
do something some other stuff and go do
all these films but I'll say you know
with it with the whole Marvel Universe
you know I'm I'm super you know at first
I didn't really understand the way it
worked you know and and and I don't even
know if I still understand completely
the way it works but I'm so grateful to
be a part of it because you know it's
they just do such good work and I think
that people the people that I've gotten
to meet and work with it's just such an
unbelievable level of talent you know I
was going to say you know last night I
came out and you know the made an
announcement about Deborah Ann Woll
who's just like the greatest ever you
know I'm so grateful she's gonna be on
the show but also I got to say you know
the ability to the opportunity that I
had to work with people like Charlie Cox
and Vincent D'Onofrio I mean these guys
are just like they're they're equal
parts they're equal parts
unbelievable artists and great great
people great human beings I'm just so
honored that that I got the opportunity
and that I have them in my life the same
way that I that I feel about those guys
that I started the walking dead with you
know it's like they're family now they
live in my heart and I'm just I'm super
grateful that I get that did I even come
close to answering the question well
yeah I think you observe anyway it's all
I'm just extremely extraordinarily
[ __ ] lucky and grateful
[Applause]
after you do like a character like Shane
for a couple seasons or even after you
work on a movie for a couple months are
you the kind of guy that can just
suddenly set aside that character and
then just move on to the next gig or do
you have to sort of like detox a little
bit like get them out of your system
maybe it's something sometimes you got
to go jump jump right in I've been doing
that I just finished move at me like
yeah you sometimes I got to jump right
in it's tough that the best thing for me
is my dogs I got I got pit bull dogs and
I there my heart and you know my man
boss Bob bosses you know boss the dog is
he's been my right-hand man for you know
forever you know he's he's 12 years old
now and and you know he comes on every
set he comes with me I like to drive you
know I like to take my truck and my dogs
too from set to set so I think the you
know it's we sort of clean out the
trailer get all my [ __ ] throw it in the
truck and I look at boss I'm like art
man it's another one down you know and
it's that ride home just him and me it's
sort of I get to come back to kind of
just being being me and he you know
there's nothing like a dog man there's
nothing oh yeah cuz as I was saying
backstage I got a I got a pet too and in
the the season season two daredevil you
know when Tony Curran is threatening the
dog I was watching that I'm like I don't
know that John's acting right there I'm
like the rage that you could see there
I'm like I can see that just being burnt
dollars real thing is that is that kind
of come close to it was it we would you
really easily channel that rage yes yeah
that's what I hoped it was it was great
- thanks man Rob from right here in
Queens New York
hey oh the the big question is we all
know agents of shield are afraid of
what's going to Manhattan and leaving
you alone but what would happen if the
Punisher crossed paths with the spirit
of vengeance Ghost Rider and how would
he win
that that's probably something I don't
know can you get into that because
that's that's speculating and even
speculation probably could end up on the
Internet in some way do you and talk as
a fan how he thinks the Punisher could
beat it oh I that's how I know you're
from Queens is you push back I don't
know you see you answer the question bro
yeah what do you think big guns now you
talk to they go down with that all right
hey oh um I'm kanessa
I'm from st. Louis Missouri what's up
Missouri hi um I was just wondering what
was your favorite scene to film while
you were doing daredevil season two yeah
like your yeah yeah yes stupid-ass you
only almost like so careful I'm like
what was my favorite I don't know man
you know it's like it's hard like
favorite scenes you know look I mean to
me the the brilliant writer named John
Kelly wrote episode 4 and he gave me
that that that monologue to write to say
at the in the graveyard you know to to
daredevil and I felt what he did was
such a brilliant writer you know and
he's he's a marine himself he served our
country and and you know he you know
what I'm saying semper fide and like you
know he just you know was such a
beautiful piece of writing because I
thought what it did is it just gave
Frank this opportunities a man who you
know ain't really about opening up you
know what I mean and he gave him this
chance to sort of tell exactly you know
where he was at and that kind of gave
him the opportunity and I think was so
brilliant about you know the the way
that Netflix kind of delivers content is
that it gives it gives you as a
performer and as the writing team it
gives you an opportunity to be very bold
with the storytelling so you can
literally do something
that perhaps the audience you can turn
your back on the audience and challenge
the audience to say you know what this
guy just went too far he did something
so brutal or so so violent that I don't
know if I can follow this guy but
anymore but then you get an opportunity
like that to say well this is where I'm
coming from and and because you don't
have to wait a week or two weeks or
three weeks for the content to come back
you know it's it's you can you can just
be more bold I don't know if that makes
sense but it totally makes sense to me
but but uh anyhow so that that was uh
that was just a gift to sort of get that
opportunity to show Frank but you know
look the the the stuff in the prison you
know working with didn't offer and the
prison fight was a was just a lot you
know like I get to the stunt team is
just incredible and those Marvel shows
all them are unbelievably ambitious and
the stunt performers that they employ I
think are the best in the business
Erik Linden is my double meet him
trained together every day he's a beast
where we're always challenging each
other pushing each other and you know
Phil severa was a just uh uh a you know
he was just you know such an honor to
work with him and and yeah so look I you
know I it's tough to say like what the
question was what was a funny scene her
favorite scene hey everything yeah I you
know I loved a whole bunch of them but
you know yeah sorry
you got there all right cool yeah you
got thing in the Netflix model do you
like the second is what's it I said with
this Netflix model do you like the fact
that it's I mean you said like you don't
have to wait but it also you don't have
to have like these forced cliffhangers
either
yeah man because you know a lot of the
times in TV it's like the last 10
minutes of an episode is sort of telling
you where you're gonna go and making you
you know wait for the next one and the
first 10 minutes of an episode is sort
of this is where we were last week and
and and it's kind of cool to just not
have to deal with that [ __ ] and just
sort of say like you know you know you
can just want when you want to walk it's
like it's a chapter of a book that's it
it's it's it's a 13 hour movie you know
it's not it's it's it's not really
episodic you know what I mean yeah cool
hi um Kelly uh you touched on this
earlier about how family was your theme
for through the whole season and I
really felt it the whole time was it
something where you were able to get the
scripts ahead of time and read all of
them since it is a series that drops on
the same day or did they tell you before
you started filming the first episode
what your motivation was what my
motivation was that the story about your
family your backstory was it something
you had ahead of time because it felt
like felt like the thread went through
the whole series it wasn't just when we
became aware of it yeah me I think the
whole thing with uh with Frank's journey
in daredevil season 2 I think the whole
thing was uh you know it was pretty
recent was pretty he was still very much
reeling and unhinged because of what
happened it was pretty was everything
was in reaction to that I don't
necessarily think it was the Punisher
you know I think it was Frank Castle you
know he there's no no part of him was
really interested in in ridding Hell's
Kitchen of the criminal element you just
want to find who did that to his family
and and tear them apart you know I mean
like that's what it was about so it's a
you know that's just kind of like where
he was at at that at that point you know
to me yeah I think who do you think is
more messed up Shane or Frank Castle not
just because of the family stuff but
just the personal angst that he carries
around with them
because they're both they both carry a
little bit of angst around of them who's
that you're asking my man I don't know
man I mean what do you know man I mean I
you know everyone's did try and do the
best they can know man hi hi my name is
Nick I'm from right here in New York I I
just wanted to tell you that and this is
just a comment about your portrayal of
the character about how you said it
means a lot to you to make him is
accurate and his come to life as
possible because of people in the
military yeah I just wanted to say that
you know you really have knocked out of
the park on this one because watching
your character it really reminded me of
two people who I knew in my life one who
was in the army and one later on of a
drill sergeant one of my drill sergeants
in basic training who I knew and your
your character really you know brought
that home reminded me of them and I just
wanted to tell you that Thank You Nick
thank you for your service yeah thank
you for your service
[Applause]
he's like Frank's superpower really is
sort of this tactical mind right like
this thing that he learned through the
military is that is that something that
you kind of glean by talking to a lot of
guys in the military just kind of get a
peek into how they they think about
things Louis because part of what I do
is the guys that I get to get to meet
and form relationships with and train
with and the things I learn and and the
privilege you know anybody if you if you
have a vet in your life you know if they
give if they give you the honor and you
have the privilege of having them open
up to you and talk about their
experience no matter what it is it's I
mean that is that's worth that that's
that's just I don't know I just feel so
unbelievable and privileged that I've
been in that kind of situation and that
that men and women have opened up to me
about their experiences and and I've
gotten to kind of you know I know how
much that's worth that's that's real
value to me and it's it's just it's such
a you know I'm just extremely lucky by
it so yeah I mean as far as like Frank's
superpower yeah you know I mean I think
it's really like kind of a testament to
the human condition it's it's it's like
at the end of the day man it's like you
know human drive human determination
human rage you know channeling that and
getting behind that you know uh you know
it's like that is a superpower yeah well
and yeah just that tactical ability it
really makes them sort of the the I
don't want to compare them to any other
superhero but sort of like the Batman of
the of the Marvel Universe the guy that
can really kind of think his way around
everything which gives him that edge I
mean that's an appeal I have for that
character anyhow let's take question hi
John a Patrick from Brooklyn a big fan
of your work particularly Walking Dead
and your work playing The Punisher it's
a little bit of a mashup question for
you cool
how would Frank Castle be able to handle
the zombie apocalypse and would he do
better than Shane did better than Shane
yeah yeah I don't think you can yeah
that's a whole different story man yeah
Frank Castle me that would make that
would make Frank Castle Carl Grimes as a
father that would be there's like a
story idea for you hey I'm will so well
question is um Frank Castle is just so
badass in season two but he's still
really relatable how did you walk the
line between just kicking ass and being
relatable hmm thanks man oh don't look
at me for the answer I got nothing not
you no thanks badges that means a lot to
me I don't know what really I don't know
I don't know I mean I you know again I
think it's just about trying to I guess
make it as personal as as possible you
know I can ask an easier question you
asked me something easier Sunday buy
that hat
so what where'd you get that hat I know
a man I was at a Comic Con and a
unbelievably awesome fan made this for
me it was very yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
awesome I wear it all the time it's
another thing that I wear them that my
wife hates too I don't know I got asked
what she hates more the beard of the hat
so I tried to put them together maybe
they'll cancel each other out I mean but
as far as the relatable question I mean
you kind of answered it before it's like
everybody has a parent everybody has a
loved one in their life everyone has you
know like so that's it it's that whether
it's a child a spouse you know whatever
it is I think that's exactly what makes
him relatable look man I think with any
of these things I mean I think like
let's you know it's probably you know at
any point by the way if you see a red
dot on me that's the Marvel folks so
because I'm getting too close to saints
look I see that red dot there my gosh it
no they would make me out first is like
a warning like I think they take me out
first row but but like
you know I just know like so let's start
like with with Shane you know I think
that you know there's you know it's like
it's like the loneliness it's like you
got to get in touch you know I think to
like play him is like oh he's this guy
who just wanted to like you know sleep
with his best friend's wife and he was
evil and [ __ ] like that I just think
you're really doing the audience a big
disservice I think it's it's like
everyone's been in that situation
they've been in love with somebody that
they can't have and they've been you
know just unbelievably you know jealous
and and and they've been unbelievably
they just got I think kind of really
sort of dive into the situation that the
characters in and feel it for real and
not not worry about am I gonna be
relatable or am I gonna be likable or
how am I gonna be funny or you know I
just don't think that stuff you know I
think you just got to go for it you know
try to try to make it make it your own
if you're on high hi I'm Joseph from
Southampton what's that bro I just
wanted to know is that like the Hamptons
the Hamptons it oh cool man oh I never
been there but I heard about it like big
parties of [ __ ] so happy transition from
what you're talking about
Judith is she Shane's baby yes course of
course I'm you realize I'm about as in
the know on that show as like yeah you
probably know more meat like they don't
you know they don't give me [ __ ] man
they're like pack your bags to get out
of here man well yes I think she will
have a giant nose and huge ears and you
would definitely see she shames baby
yeah so much Oh Kimmy that's what I
meant when I said Carl Grimes
I said Carl Grimes not Judith that would
make Frank you've been messing up left
and right bro I know man I'm just as
potent I know okay say who what
okay well if chris hardwick says it it
must be true it's hi hi my name is
Amanda I'm from the city so in daredevil
season two I loved Frank and Karen's
relationship I think I'm not the only
one so I was here for the big
announcement yesterday thank you um so I
was wondering what your favorite part of
their dynamic is oh man I I just
everything I really look I love working
with her she's just she's just awesome
she's brilliant she's she's so smart and
and she's a bold actress she's
courageous and and you know look I I
don't know how much I can say I mean
like I just yeah I can't see [ __ ] dude I
just really really dig her I really
really dig her and and I I think um yeah
I I dig it as much as you I just I love
like days that I know that I'm working
with her are like good as days yeah yeah
those those season two scenes between
you two it it was compelling because she
could see sort of she looked at a man
and not just the monster and she could
see like the human in there and not just
like a maniac and that and that really
came came out with both of you guys's
performance they come it's a very I mean
Karen page is an unbelievably
fascinating character and her backstory
and all the secrets and all the stuff
that it's just it's a very very cool
character mm-hmm hello hey my name is
Alex for you I'm from Brazil what's up
man Brazil don't ask me about that
what do you mean I'm just gonna shake my
head no okay oh really
all right cool man so [ __ ] Frank Castle
has sometimes crossed the path of
Captain America in the comics and do you
think your Punisher would raise a hand
to Captain America would raise a hand I
think that's probably a that's where I'm
a bad cop and I'm gonna say probably
can't answer what do you think man
well if we're going off of the comics
Civil War no okay okay well there you go
Brazil
ha ha hey my name is Jack what do you
find to be the most daunting aspect of
portraying the Punisher daunting see
they're asking acting questions to man
it's not just me
no not you're great man I'm this one say
what would you say you say the end [ __ ]
I just I just want to piggyback off what
you said would you I love you too look
uh I don't want to get too into it you
know I a look guys it's a tough thing
because we're doing it you know like I
just think the head the head space you
know it's a dark it's a dark to dark
dark place to live in us but Union you
know it's just a dark place to to
explore you know I think that's what's
you know daunting about it but it's good
you know
ha ha ha ha not the fans dealing with
all these questions I'm sure this is
terrifying
what's that without dealing with all of
us I love y'all know I mean like like I
want to just do I am me what's good like
I just really want to do right by you I
really wanted right by I know how much
this he's not mine he's you know comment
I've said before you know you know comic
book character you know the the act of
reading a comic means that you you have
these captions you have this art and you
have these words but it requires the
reader to infuse so much of their own
imagination it's it's so these
characters they live in the hearts and
the imagination of the fans so it's like
there's a there's a sense of belonging
there that I respect and I agree with so
it's like you got to get this right you
can't just
you can't just ignore all everything
that's been out there and just you know
you got to do your work you got it you
know so so yeah so I guess that's a
little that's a little dog but no
talking to y'all is like now I'm not
even a little bit nerd
I'm nervous I'm gonna mess up and say
some [ __ ] that I'm not supposed to say
but uh I like I love you guys no [ __ ]
you love you nice man yeah well you just
um outside furniture you also just
wrapped with the baby driver with Edgar
Wright correct yeah I'm just curious
about that's coming on in 2017 I think
it doesn't budget yeah yeah I mean like
yeah so I mean just like talk about the
experience of working with Edgar cuz
that guy I mean he's he's a fan as well
of all this stuff but just like his
directing style and and just how you
kind of clicked on that that said you
know Edgar's great manitou it's a great
great cast of Kevin Spacey and Jon Hamm
and Jamie Foxx and so Albert you know
like they're uh it's great look it's a
super ambitious movie you know again on
that one I don't even know much opposed
to say but you know it's the whole movie
is kind of it's just got to be a dope
movie man I think it's going to be cool
but accountants coming out accountants
coming out next like next yeah that
should be cool and there's some cool you
know there's some cool other films
coming out I mean there's a ton of cool
films that I had nothing to do with it
or coming up but but you know I got a
bunch of movies coming out this year
that I think should be pretty cool well
you've been you've been lucky to work
with a lot of amazing directors and then
very early screen with a lot of great
actors but from the directing component
like what makes a good director in your
mind like what's the kind of director
that you want to work with um you know
for me the thing that's the same and all
the greats the thing that's the same is
that they have this ability to have
completely done their work so they they
know it they know the story they have a
very specific vision they've done so
much work and they know they just
they're they're extremely prepared but
have this ability to
completely let everything go in the
moment and create an atmosphere where
literally anything can happen where it
can change on a dime and it's alive and
it's free so it's this crazy kind of
achieved combination of unbelievable
preparation and unbelievable freedom
that they just inspire everybody on set
it just becomes a set of we're full you
know creativity can flourish and flow
and all the great ones the great you
know the great ones that I've worked
with they're all so different but they
all have that same thing in common do
you like a director that's going to show
up and say alright John this this is
what I want this one or just once you
let you show up and do your own thing
and then gives you like notes or a nudge
or whatever just both man you know it's
like both you know like just you know no
no one to hold them no one to fold them
you know like no you know like you know
when they when your need to get in there
but not you know don't don't don't
micromanage every little thing and be
smart enough to you know let some actor
figure feel like they're figuring it out
on its own it's Imboden you know what I
mean but like they create in the
atmosphere man that's that's that I
think is like the the biggest thing but
yeah Ben I've been super lucky that the
folks have gotten to work for ya and you
learn so much it's the best thing about
this job is you just you just keep
learning and keep growing you keep
trying to you know get get better you
know mm-hmm yeah like absorb everything
around you I guess Sirte yeah hi John my
little wall so I'm from Teaneck New
Jersey and Teaneck
yes sir cool um so as we don't know
where any of y'all are from I don't know
any of these towns man but it sort of
sounds like you do like to única the
house yeah but see I mean that's a cool
name Tina Tina yeah anyway sorry it
sounds like a Marvel villain [ __ ] right
um
so as we see that Daredevils going to
get his own team with the defenders is
it possible we're gonna see Punisher get
in his own team like Thunderbolts I'm
gonna stop you there but it reduction is
much like to see that I would very much
like to see that
maybe the Marvel gods are listening hi
I'm Jared I'm from New York
John I got a question if your kids get
bully in school or your neighbor gets
give you a hard time
do you ever think about letting the
Punisher out of them well he would go to
jail but what do you think John I'm kind
of wondering if I should cut out that
question I mean I mean you know I mean
nah I mean uh I'm now just you know I
mean my boys you know my boys they they
[Music]
they're five and three man you know it
but but they yeah I plead the fifth
brother
yeah thank you for that whoever said
that bro there's a gangster in the house
and [ __ ] yeah hey there how's it going
John this heiress from New York hey man
just want to let you know I just want
two quick things it's armed
first of all with you all your dramatic
characters what do you go home and relax
with like with three movies would you go
to decompress ooh I don't know that I
did you know you know I think I think a
lot of the times row you know for me
like for a part like Shane or pressure
so like a lot of these guys like a Grady
who I played in Fury the did the the job
is not to decompress right the job is to
do the opposite of that so the job is to
like get away all the [ __ ] that
would make you decompress for me
that's how I do it like I want to stay
in it you know like I don't want to be
the kind of guy who's at the nightclub
or you know I've said before like eating
a bunch of Chinese food and like like
they'd be like all right now we're going
to play the scene where like you lost
your [ __ ] best friend or some [ __ ]
you know ii mean like i I don't like
doing that very much
but if I were kind of watch them stuff
to just chill I guess you know what I
wasn't working I like Dazed and Confused
I can watch that movie you know I can
watch that movie over and over and over
and over again and it's a true romance I
feel the same way about and you know
honestly like anything any scores like
Goodfellas Cape Fear like it like any of
those it's just like I just think
they're the funniest [ __ ] but you
know I can just watch those over and
over again so I don't know I don't know
if that answers your question
you know man there's so much good stuff
to to watch now man like there's so much
good stuff to watch you know and so so
yeah anyway yeah what do you like
everything yeah my right arm and I cool
coo coo
canna quick take out a picture of you oh
yeah oh I do it every more bro oh yeah
[Applause]
when a you and I have talked before
about books you auu read quite a bit
like you made you've given me some good
book suggestions before so what are you
checking out right now are you reading
anything yeah I mean look the book that
I'm like kind of like pumping you know
whenever anybody asks you know the book
I think everybody should read is this
book called all involved by Ryan Gattis
it's a it's it's it's an unbelievable
blow your minds it's it's about takes
place in the wake sort of the in the
days of the LA riots but it's told
through the the point of view of a bunch
of different characters and it's it's
just fun it's so good man it's such a
badass book and I just uh I just read
another book called ghetto side which is
really interesting I'm kind of a sort of
staying sort of in that same theme but
like yeah if I was going to suggest one
book right now like check out all ball
by Ryan Gattis it'll it'll blow your
mind how good this book is it's a bad
bad book man does he know that the I
mean I would want to know if like
someone was out there pimping my book a
little bit yeah Ryan yeah man he you
know actually it's like I'm such a I'm
such a [ __ ] on the computer and stuff
but but I use the old Twitter man and I
followed him you know me I was like this
might work you know and I like wrote to
him how much and then yeah we actually
met and year we got together and then
his his old lady is real real cool she
works at a school out in LA you know in
pretty rough community whatever so I
went I went to the school and talked to
the kids they were putting on a play and
they were awesome and like so like yeah
we have a relationship now he came to my
birthday party on a lot but and he's
working on his next but but I promise
you
if y'all are into that kind of thing
y'all like books like read read this
book it's called all involved by Ryan
Gattis I promise you you will [ __ ]
love this book I probably promise you if
not you don't come throw [ __ ] on me like
you do whatever you want so I'm not
worried about it it's that good of a
book it's funny because it sounds like
you had a bit of the fan moment with the
100% I was like you know when I left
like I called my mom like mom the
coolest thing happened like like oh my
god you wouldn't believe who I like and
he came and he talked to me and like
yeah yeah yeah no he said he's a beast
man yeah anyway yeah super cool yeah
that's awesome yeah
hi I'm Rachel I'm from New Jersey
hey I'm really nervous and I love don't
be nervous stop don't be nervous nothing
to be nervous about
um my question is another acting
question I'm sorry it's okay
hey I'm cool if you're quiet just don't
want to bore this you know the snot out
of y'all yeah no you would never okay so
obviously like we all read the comics
we've all know the Punisher and we've
seen you in the in daredevil but like in
your show how are we gonna see you
portray the Punisher like are you gonna
put specific mannerisms like how are you
gonna make it your own so that it's not
a repeat of what we've already seen move
that's it was such you're such a sweet
person yeah it's a good question what
yeah probably can't answer right now I
want to go like slam my head into a wall
yeah she's like yeah oh you mean I can't
just do the same thing it doesn't work
I was listening uh yeah I I can't I
can't go to I you know I do like that
she set the bar really low for you it's
like yeah just so uh you know don't
don't repeat yourself man right right
Thanks knives something else today we're
gonna be completely horrified about yeah
thank you for that you did such a good
job don't screw it up yeah can we I feel
it anyways I know I know I know I'm
gonna do my best that's all I can say do
you get do you get actor anxiety like
you know when you're when you're doing a
movie with DeNiro and I know we've
talked about this before but you show up
and you're like I'm not I'm not good
enough to be here right now I'm and like
experience that anxiety I mean I think
that you know the true greats I think
the true greats it's just the same thing
I was talking about the directors the
true greats they figure out a way to get
rid of all that [ __ ] because if they
have if you're walking in you know I
think only an [ __ ] walks around like
a movie star right like bit like like
letting everybody know you know hey I'm
you know what I mean but like the true
artists like the true great ones they
they dispel that and
been that way across the board with with
with a you know I'll never forget you
you know I did this movie Sicario and I
only worked a few days on it and I came
on you know Emily Blunt man I mean first
of all great director with Denny like
you know this guy just totally did what
I was talking about the you know he's up
there with the with the Scorsese's and
the Polanski's and the great ones that
I've gotten to work with but you know
Emily Blunt like you know just the way
she was she just made me you know it was
a tough part because I had to kind of
come in there and like pick her up at a
bar then make out with her then try to
kill her and then like it torture in a
car like those were my days and if she
was sort of like you know she was sort
of like I'm Emily Blunt you're you know
that [ __ ] from the zombie show like
that would like that would be you know
I'm saying like that would have been a
tough thing you know but instead she
just like had that ability of been like
let's do this like let's do and I think
the great ones you know get the bet you
know do so I and I think it also at the
end of the day man we all put our pants
on one leg at a time I met a thing maybe
some of y'all do two at a time but we
all put wear pants or skirts or whatever
you know what the hell I'm saying like
we all eat we all go to the bathroom and
we all you know we all do the same [ __ ]
right so like there's no reason to I'm a
think you got to be respectful of
everyone but I don't think you need to
fear anybody like I just don't think
that that like it's going to do anything
really for you and I think that a lot of
times there's so much I don't want to
get like political but I think there's
so much like misunderstanding and in our
country right now and we're so polarized
and people kind of believe in and want
different things and I just think like
we're all so much closer to the same
that anybody thinks we all love our
families we all want the best for each
other we you know and it's like trying
to say oh these kinds of people do this
with you it's just it's it's kind of get
you know it's all fear-based it's all
being a huge big big for lack of a
better word but like just like a huge
wimp you know like I think that like you
know it's like if you you know don't be
scared of people man you know what I
mean like we all want the same thing
that's what I think yeah but that also
sounds like that also sounds like good
lessons before your now that sort of the
captain of the ship the top of the Call
Sheet
on on this on this series and it seems
like having learned all those lessons
kind of like prepped you for this this
gig now know
I mean I I'm gonna do the best I can man
yeah I hope so
uh yeah yeah I'm yeah yeah I mean just
about treating other people who are
spending you should always treat
everybody with with with with yeah hell
yeah you know me but like no matter what
your it doesn't matter yeah no matter
what's like we're all everybody on that
crew I like going to work together man
it's like let's make this [ __ ] work
you know hey how you doing John money
brother Dave from New Jersey how
everybody my question is out of the
whole entire Marvel Universe who would
you as the punisher like to have a
one-on-one fight with and why I can't
man I can't why I mean like I would you
like to see me have a one-on-one fight
with probably gambit say again Andy huh
well what you can't say that always like
I I think you mentioned this to me
before uh like the Joker in another
universe we get you could talk about the
Joker right yeah I don't think I can
because then there was this whole thing
alright okay well then I'm sorry guys I
stuck I'm sorry I'm sorry bro that's
true question al I know it worse I think
yeah yeah yeah say you try hi my name is
iris what's up iris what you do you inky
what cyrusi uh-huh I wish I could do
that [ __ ] hey I'm John he like right
would that be fun
no I mean be weird I don't know if you
mean you sound way better than you did I
couldn't sell that I don't think I can
sell like if you did like not with the
beard and the hand Yeah right okay yeah
you're right I'm gonna work on it sorry
hi iris if you could be any no if you
could who is your favorite hero or food
in answer was your favorite villain or
hero in any universe just personally or
book even or like you know movie or etc
can I expand it like that yes yes it
doesn't have to be super heated yeah I
got you I got you I got you
I got you look I said you know I said it
before but like I mean I don't even know
how many of you guys know the film but I
think like Clint I do think like
Clarence from food to romance right like
players would like like I think here's
this guy that's like completely like
unassuming but it's like you you know
like for love for like his family like
you cross him like there's no lengths
that he won't go to and and I also dig
that like he kind of like keeps it cool
the whole time you know what I mean and
I say again yeah man what Elvis isn't
right and like and like you know man I
just I just I just love I love that
character and I love that film so much
because it's so you know he's such a
it's such a humble character too you
know he doesn't there's like no bravado
there's no bluster he did not I mean
it's it's a really cool really cool
character yeah yeah it's such a good
line man yeah what was a when when
you're a younger guy before you were
doing that says as a job what was like a
movie speech that you would kind of
recite to yourself in the mirror or
whatever the new one too and there's so
many but like me at me and my best
friend dougie thornell man we would we
would like you guys remember that movie
Johnny be good oh yeah remember that
like who Mikey John Wayne who wants to
grab a root and hang on you know you
know you I'm a winner if you want to be
a loser you go to Russia I'm a winner
I'm an American
yeah I mean yeah anyway yeah we like
those you know prevention the Nerds you
know that kind of said yeah yeah you're
an 80s kid I forgot yeah I'm old as hell
did yeah but like um yeah yeah yeah
anyway sorry
hey Jeremy Freeman I'm from a little
moon town of Melbourne Australia
okay what's up dude um my question is
and it's hard like being one of the last
ones not to kind of sound a bit
repetitive but how do you like psych
yourself up for the role of the Punisher
and for instance daredevil season 2 what
was it like in between takes like do you
like talk to the other actors or do you
like rush off
trailer food or like decompress
uh yeah daredevil season two what was my
problem yeah you know yeah I don't I
don't uh I don't go to the trailer no I
but I don't I don't um yeah not talking
about it's pretty it's pretty pretty
pretty serious man yeah like I'm pretty
your music helps a lot and you know and
yeah I don't yeah don't I don't I don't
yeah yeah not the trailer not the
trailer that's one other thing if they
were to ask you to appear in fear the
walking dead because it's like a prequel
would you do it um yeah I don't think
that I don't think I would be I don't
know man I don't know I would have to
see what it was that they wanted me to
do I guess you know but I probably
wouldn't be allowed to do it you know
what I mean guys gonna be pretty busy
for a while so I don't know a opening
like that show you like you like fear
yeah cool cool yeah no me too no it's
dope yeah it's cool yeah I love ya yeah
but I could imagine gets a little weird
in between takes if you're having like
this intense scene and then next minute
you're just cracking jokes and yeah I
don't do that but knowledge yeah like
yeah yeah don't cuz you lose that I have
no problem with people who do do that I
just don't do that
yeah I don't I don't do that yeah guys
we have time for two more questions all
right
oh [ __ ] sorry oh there's so many more
would you say I love you too Matt thanks
is something totally different though
you like
like what all right over here Oh movie
all right I'm Marne from Plainfield New
Jersey yeah um actually Robert Kirkman
yesterday datum say that Shane was dudas
bad on the panel oh yeah um so he'll say
anything um my question is we probably
know that you have to like eat healthy
and stay fit but what is your favorite
cheat meal oh that's a good question
though that is a good one so bad I
haven't had you know yeah I'm not like
it for you yeah will you you gotta wait
we got we got some time can't I'm like
I'm on the no yeah that's got a great
tie let's talk about diet like actors
[ __ ] well yes uh I would do like
anything for some pizza man okay like a
pie can I can't a kid that's cool cuz
you're you're surrounded by the best
frickin pizza in the world
[Music]
legally I really hope on your rap party
it's just all pizza like yes you can see
yeah you know do you want to do the
speed thing can we do that or is this I
don't know how many we can go through
but guys want to do like try to do as
quick questions as you possibly can will
try to do one-word answer alright I'm
gonna cut you okay as fast we can ready
go yes now what's up um Jeremy from Long
Island yeah yeah let's not do the
intraday
love you Jeremy but how would shane
handle negan you beat his ass alright
faster faster hi what draws you to dark
characters the darkness there yeah what
was your favorite weapon to use in
daredevil season 2 what was your
favorite weapon that's so hard oh man
there's so many you are shorter glass
might slit that do
how did you react when you got cast as
Punisher super super happy super scared
who's your favorite character on the
daredevil cast Oh Dicky enhancing all of
them all of all of them all of them
sorry do I love them all I really do
love them all
sorry sorry while your speed rounding
questions cuz this fan give you a gift
yeah come on come on man go get yeah
okay I just want Brad loved the one
batch to batch scene thank you and I
want to say I really like to see
spider-man where he gets turned into the
man spider and you have to track him
down
hell is here Tom Holland ooh tom hollie
Tom Allen Tom Holland y'all that's my
major role did you like more your pardon
Walking Dead or Punisher I love it it's
like I can't I love what I'm doing while
I'm doing it man yeah I can't I can't
pick sorry
who'd win in a fight Punisher orbona
sure you came back to Rage Against the
Machine I want to see what other metal
music you kind of really like uh duh
Danzig I was just some dancer yeah
Danzig um come on man come on really not
what was it better working with Ben
Affleck or um Brad Pitt ah I love the
both favorites yeah I love them both
love them both yeah what would you add
the punish Hillary Clinton or Donald
Trump
[Applause]
this will be the lock that would get him
a call from The Secret Service either
way so no this would be the last
question as actors who would win you or
Charlie Cox as actors siting straight up
fighting ass Charlie Cox do you think
the Punisher and Deadpool will be really
good friends huh
okay um who do you want to win your
punisher versus Tom Hollands spider-man
and also can I take a quick selfie of
you Punisher come on from there yes uh
have people openly expressed to you not
to [ __ ] up the role of Punisher yes all
the time dude you just sit again thank
you okay you can have one but not the
other would you rather be able to feel
sex or taste food or taste food but you
can't feel sex you can feel sex but you
can't Oh feel sex if you can feel that
you can't taste your food if you can
taste your food you can't feel sex for
the rest of your life which one house
brick addy I love my wife
eats our tacos whoo it's a pizza man
beta how violent can we expect the
Punisher to be n come on man I love you
bro but come on uh liquor or beer whoo
liquor or beer look night drinking man
I'm working here how hard was it to do
the voice for Punisher hard right
daredevil Jessica Jones or Luke Cage
first season what was your favorite
favorite I like them all I like them all
there guy mean defenders yeah hi um I
wanted to know for one actor to another
were like what advice you would give
don't worry about what you got don't
worry about getting into the right rooms
worry about what you're gonna do when
you get in those rooms yeah what was
your favorite role that you portrayed in
TV or movies oh [ __ ] I love them all I
really can't pick but I love them all I
love them all I love you too I
appreciate it thank you I'm sorry
defenders did you get to hang out with
the the dog from season 2 it you got to
was your dog did I what did you like
hang out a little bit a little bit a
look yeah I got I wanted to hang out
with the more bridge count yeah yeah
yeah yeah we're all done okay done what
did you guys
[Applause]
thanks guys thanks a lot
you